perhaps the easiest entry point into
overwatch for all you shooter fans out
there is a man called soldier 76 he's
got a rifle he's got a gun and he runs
around a lot Chris Watters here with
Eric Tay talking about overwatch hero
guides and we're gonna tell you what it
takes to get into the field and be
effective as soldier 76 Eric yeah
soldier 76 a very Call of Duty like
character accessible for everyone one of
the probably best starting characters at
least on offense so he's got his heavy
pulse rifle right and this thing seems
pretty straightforward fires great
mid-range damage
great for sort of hassling people down
main lanes and keeping fire on supports
any sports sort of keeping them out of
the way if you're firing a distance
though keep in mind that the longer you
hold it down it does create a little bit
of spread on the bullets so burst-fire
butter that butter that butter that if
you want accurate head shots at distance
is your way to go yeah like you said you
know you want to make sure to not just
hold it down spray-and-pray
that's decent up close but definitely
not a viable strategy far away in terms
of optimal range for soldier 76 it's a
little bit away because you can do
damage at that distance you don't want
to be up in anyone's face you know cuz
they might have a better close-range
weapon than you but fortunately you've
got your sprint ya sprint is a great
ability it lets you get back from you
know respawn points faster also lets you
get away from enemies if you're not
feeling the business that's going on at
the time because you know sometimes
you're getting peppered so if you
definitely want to run away that allows
you to use the biotic field which then
lets you heal yourself which is a great
little tool as well absolutely mobility
and running away from fights is totally
a good strategy and overwatch you want
to stay alive you want to be in the
fight for as long as possible
soldier 76 does have that staying power
thanks to his mobility and like you said
Eric his biotic field you throw this
thing down
it does healing in an area it can also
help your allies out super helpful for
support or other offensive and defensive
characters who don't have a huge health
pool for whom just a few seconds in that
biotic field will bring them back up to
full fighting strength yeah and it's
also really good on things like the
payload because you can put it on the
payload and you know you can keep
attacking keep fighting keep sustaining
your health while you know in the fray
so pop that thing don't save it for a
rainy day your team is always taking
damage you should always be doing what
you can to heal that damage now in terms
of working with other character
one of my favorite matchups is at
Soldier 76 and mercy not for the healing
abilities but for mercy's damage boost
because people expect to take damage
from soldier 76 at range you expect to
deal damage at range but a lot of people
have sort of calibrated in yeah I could
take a few bullets from soldier 76 and I
got to get out of the way or I can
return fire a little bit but with the
damage boost it gives it that little
edge and it can make real problems for
people especially supports at range
what makes that combo so good especially
for supporting a push or for keeping
people off the point like you said it's
very strong you know like people
underestimate the power of that just
that added boost it's just a few shots
can take down some of those supports
it's really strong
and it goes really well with his hilux
rocket which is his other ability which
with your right-click you can basically
shoot like a grenade and it does a lot
of damage it pretty much goes in a
straight line it's not like a jump rack
grenade it's pretty much like a rocket
absolutely and that thing again you want
to be using that as much as you can
because little by little that's going to
stack up how much damage you're out
putting on the other team now who do you
target with that thing it's great for
peeking around corners and taking down
those turrets that bastion that Torbjorn
turret giving them some trouble also if
someone's really up in your face shoot
it at the ground it's gonna do some
splash damage it's gonna give you a
little bit of room and it's also great
for just that finishing blow on someone
you've engaged you sort of shoot them
with your bullets a little bit you start
seeing where they're gonna flee lead
them with the rockets boom great on
tracers trying to get in your face as
you said one shot right into her face
she's dead also good for kind of getting
enemies behind covered because it's
going to get that little splash damage
and I think it does do a little bit of a
knock back so it's a nice little kind of
like maybe you get them off the edge but
why not now let's talk altima to the
tactical visor aka
aimbot mode yep just like you said it's
aimed by he says I've got you in my
sights and basically the reticle is like
a lot bigger basically you can hold and
spray-and-pray at that point because
it's gonna lock on to whoever you're
kind of like general direction that and
it melts supports and he reloads faster
and the reloading faster so key because
you want to be pouring on the damage
when your ultimate is up targeting those
supports you'll do good damage to a tank
for sure but like if you can get a few
offense or defense characters in your
sights when you pop that alt it's going
to be trouble for them and it's going to
be gravy for you so you soldier 76 to
keep fire on the enemy whether you're
pushing down the main lane or doing some
little flanking runs with your sprint
and then coming back around to your team
healing yourself you're a very
survivable character
and you're very versatile character but
also one of the easiest to learn so get
out there and have some fun and you know
what don't waste your time shooting
Reinhardt shield you're just not going
to make a big enough of a dent to bring
that thing down in a meaningful way find
another target and do your thing
for more overwatch hero guides check out
our playlists on YouTube and give us a
subscribe or head on over to
gamespot.com